[Music]
most people don't do their hobby as
their profession but this is my hobby
this is my passions what I'd love to do
I love building businesses this is fun
for me like I'd rather be doing this
than playing for tonight I'd rather be
doing this than skiing I'd rather be
doing this the rock climbing yoga
cooking watching Game of Thrones this is
my hobby and like I keep telling
everybody in the macro to live their
hobby with their passion their happiness
and and I'm doing it yeah I've been
living
whereas these up in my head to try to
reach it to the top floor I can see you
focus on single back on two days
hello Sasha what up what up
[Music]
the first 35 people we hired had zero
days of creative experience and then I
told half of that in a room just like
this not too far from here you're all
making content and literally unlike any
questions and they're like I don't know
how to make content I was like and this
was really the answer I was like google
it I was like we'll get you Photoshop
and google it like that was literally
like real to me like very real very not
real to a creative agency land like if
you ask me what's the biggest difference
between Boehner 2019 and Boehner 2011
and could Sascha take something from
that it's just doing mechanical each is
really feeling it I think I think it is
algorithmic yeah I think that's right
please for me yeah yeah
things don't hook me right away I just a
hundred percent but I do think about
here's what I would say I don't think
our IG TV thumbnail and titles are good
at all or copy and they're crushing
because I think there got it that's
that's where my thesis is coming think
the first three seconds really matter
the copy really matters the thumbnail
really matters everything matters
I love how people thinking people the
masks millions of followers like cuz
they got lucky Twitter I hope you're
doing super well just wanted to wish
everybody a tremendous Wednesday and
nothing but health and happiness and a
little fun thing that I think a lot of
people tend not to do I recommend if you
have a second right now to go into your
address book hit the letter D and call
somebody you haven't spoken to in a long
time and just say hello and hi you know
what's funny I'm gonna do it eating your
own dog food what a bright honestly no
joke I'm just calling you to say that I
love you and I'm so grateful for these
many many years that we've gotten to
work together at Wine Library you're
just such a wonderful dude and I just
wanted you to know it how are you ma'am
I know you haven't that's why it's fun
to just kind of do this once in a blue
moon you know what I mean
I think about you a bunch and I just
want to do a better job of just calling
sometimes literally that's it you good
seems like a lot of the operation stuff
is getting better and better and more
efficient every day I love it man I
appreciate ping me anytime okay do that
it may put some sort of weird calendar
thing on like November like on September
7th and like just call me every year on
that day or something just at least once
a year I love you pal see you bye now
you get addicted and you're like kind of
like
I just wanted to call and say I love
your face I'll tell you the thing that I
would highly recommend is maybe making a
comic of something that's actually
happening at this moment like the colic
you know that comic parents buying
[ __ ] into kids into college we should
have made a comic on that like it should
have been like a bunch of people like
Gary did you hear what happened like and
then and my reply would be like what do
you think I've been telling you
you know like stuff like that social
comment take like of the moment in the
same way you're thinking about that but
we're cool with that Chris I'm into it
let's go literally like like look the
best way to get [ __ ] to happen is to do
go find Mike Boyd get Mike Boyd find his
number call them get keyed on the phone
and let him make sure he's you know the
other thing is I don't want you to waste
time so you should be [ __ ] texting me
and saying like I want to make a comic
on this this just happened what do you
think and then I'm gonna reply one of
them every three times and like we're
gonna go empathy bros a-and if you had
to air one soft cheese with a poppy bros
a empty rose a fish o with fish empathy
rose a like a chicken yeah empathy rose
a
maybe you stake their empathy bro say
alright but finally if you had to just
pair it with a dessert what would it be
like a coconut cream pie that or maybe
just like a sprinkle cupcake the empathy
rose a I was fighting to stay alive the
whole time
oh I think you should do uh make a piece
of content that's like a spin the bottle
I'm gonna kiss one of you so get ready
the rock I know you've always wanted it
yeah so perfect I want to give myself
nobody that was amazing it was my wish
everything it was mine this was my first
time and I know you say like it's
gratitude so I guess I just wanted to
see if you could elaborate more on there
well if we're supposed to a lot of
practice right I've been really grinding
and then working like this my whole life
so you know what I mean
it is gratitude it's also being in your
right spot like I love doing this like
I've said it over and over you can
probably clip 13 different times I've
said in the last month like this is my
hobby yeah this is my passions what I'd
love to do I love building businesses
this is fun for me like I'd rather be
doing this than playing for night I'd
rather be doing this than skiing I'd
rather be doing this in rock climbing
yoga cooking watching Game of Thrones
this is my hobby
most people don't do their hobby as
their profession like I just don't think
most people are living their hobby right
and like and that's that's it it's kind
of like today when I gave the advice to
like go to your contacts and hit the
letter D and call somebody well then I
did it and like I keep telling everybody
in the macro to live their hobby live
their passion live their happiness and
and I'm doing it like I only give advice
or hot takes or opinions or thoughts or
hypothesis on [ __ ] I'm actually living
so how do those people that want to do
that but they're just too scared to like
take the leap they're scared because of
judgement and they're scared because
they buy [ __ ] or live a lifestyle they
can't afford which is why that's where
all my content goes I think about where
all my contacts stop buying dumb [ __ ]
stop worrying about other people's
opinions why because if you do those two
things you can actually do what you love
almost everybody can do what they love
but are they willing to live a lifestyle
where they only make $31,000 a year
that's know do you want to be happy or
do you want to be perceived as happy
right you know people end up buying like
this is to want this Lexus or does he
like the way it makes him look to
everybody else you know that's my
[ __ ] question
it's not super complicated it's a very
simple question because the part the
second part of that statement which I
say often is if he's got that Lexus
because he's insecure and using it as a
cosign and that's coming at the expense
of him not being able to leave a job he
hates where he's making 84k to go start
a Star Trek blog while he has a side job
making 47 K that Lexus is bad if he's
happy that likes this is amazing I guess
like if I was in like if you're talking
to me yes I'm saying that I guess my
concern would be can this be done long
term by the macro like
I guess I would be afraid that it would
just almost in a way that it would be a
short term cuz you're not an
entrepreneur I here start tracking I'm
like okay I'm gonna start a Star Trek
podcast then I'm gonna take 18 months
it's gonna pop that I'm gonna be able to
you know I'll do something on the side
but then I'll be able to start like
selling hoodies which Star Trek like I
think I can become an entrepreneur I
think I can get to a hundred thousand on
any [ __ ] idea but I'm talented and
I'm an entrepreneur it's okay if you're
not an entrepreneur but it still speaks
to its truth it is possible and mate and
like and if it's not long-term like you
didn't build it then go get a [ __ ]
job my thing is like you could always
get the [ __ ] job
you could always succumb why are people
starting by folding their hand
play because the system told you to vote
rant because it put you in detention if
you were rowdy and charismatic but I
didn't [ __ ] listen to you system
I didn't [ __ ] listen to you system I
lived it because I didn't respect it
because I thought it was a facade and I
ended up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]